When she was seven, when she would visit her grandmother, Alexa would look through the books that her grandfather had owned back when he was alive. What she liked especially was finding the books where he'd made little notes in the margins.
Alexa七岁时，每当去祖母家，她都会翻看祖父生前拥有的那些书。她特别喜欢找那些他在书页空白处留有小笔记的书。
So that was the part that was really compelling.
所以那部分内容真的很吸引人。
Because they were hints about who he was.
因为那是关于他为人的线索。
Exactly. And a lot of times they were really critical. He would write, I steadfastly disagree. Or something like that. Or he would write, Ah!, if he really liked something.
没错。而且很多时候他的评价非常尖刻。他会写下“我坚决反对”，或者类似的话。如果他真的很喜欢什么，他就会写“啊！”。
As a kid, over the course of about a year, she systematically divided the books into two piles, the ones with markings, and the ones without. And then she tried to read all the ones with markings. Her grandfather was a playwright and a teacher, and the books were creaky old books from the 1930s about theater and about how to write plays. It was thrilling. And when she was 11, she wrote her very first play, using the rules in the books, rules from another generation.
小时候，在大约一年的时间里，她系统地把这些书分成了两堆：有批注的和没批注的。然后她试着读完了所有有批注的书。她的祖父是一位剧作家兼老师，这些书是20世纪30年代关于戏剧和剧本写作的陈旧书籍，读起来嘎吱作响。这太令人兴奋了。11岁时，她根据书中的规则——那些来自上一代人的规则——写出了她的第一部剧本。
These were archaic rules, like start your play with lots of exposition, which was really in vogue at the time. So I started mine with a butler, whose name I believe was Manson, picking up a phone, saying stuff like, no, the lady and gentleman are not home right now. Why, at a fancy charity ball. Yes, he's still drinking too much, and she's having an affair with a gardener. Whom shall I say is calling?
那是一些老派的规则，比如让你的剧本以大量的背景介绍开头，这在当时非常流行。所以我用了个管家开头，我记得他叫曼森，他接起电话说，不，先生和太太现在不在家。哎呀，在一个高级慈善舞会上。是的，他还是喝得太多了，而她正和园丁有染。请问是谁在打电话？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm not kidding.
我没开玩笑。
You were 11.
你才11岁。
By the time I got to college and I started to actually take writing classes, it was brought to my attention that stage directions shouldn't be things like, there follows a mighty howling of wind. And one of the things my teacher-- who was not a young man, by any means-- said was, he was like, sweetheart, we don't use sotto voce anymore to mean he whispers. We just write, whispers.
当我上大学并开始真正上写作课时，我注意到舞台提示不应该是“随后传来一阵强烈的风啸声”这样的东西。我的老师——他绝对不是个年轻人——说，亲爱的，我们不再用“sotto voce”（轻声地）来表示耳语了。我们直接写“耳语”就行。
But of all the books on her grandfather's shelves, there was one book that affected her more than the others. It had lots of her grandfather's writing in the margins.
但在祖父书架上的所有书中，有一本书对她的影响超过了其他任何一本。书页空白处写满了她祖父的笔迹。
And he was very critical, so it was very rare that he would write, Ah!, exclamation point. And there were more Ahs! in Moss Hart's autobiography, which is called Act One , then I think almost any of the other books that he had.
他非常挑剔，所以他写下“啊！”（后面还加个感叹号）是非常罕见的。而在莫斯·哈特的自传《第一幕》中，出现的“啊！”比他收藏的其他任何书都要多。
Moss Hart was a Broadway playwright, the man who directed My Fair Lady with Julie Andrews and Rex Harrison, who was married to another then-luminary named Kitty Carlisle, who people these days mostly remember as a game show panelist back in the 1960s. The book details how he started as a kid in the Bronx, found something he just loved to do, which was to make plays. Reading it as a child, Alexa had that experience that you have sometimes as a kid. She did not understand everything in the book, but she understood enough to know that she really, really liked it.
莫斯·哈特是一位百老汇剧作家，曾执导朱莉·安德鲁斯和雷克斯·哈里森主演的《窈窕淑女》，他的妻子是当时另一位名流基蒂·卡莱尔，而如今人们大多只记得她是20世纪60年代的游戏节目嘉宾。这本书详细记录了他如何从布朗克斯的一个孩子开始，找到了他真正热爱的事情——编剧。儿时的Alexa阅读此书时，产生了一种孩子们有时会有的体验。她并不能理解书中所有的内容，但她理解得足够多，知道自己非常、非常喜欢它。
Like, I knew what was going on and this book was fun. It drove him so powerfully, and it seemed to make him so happy.
就像，我知道发生了什么，而且这本书很有趣。它极大地驱动着他，似乎让他非常快乐。
She read Act One by Moss Hart over and over. She memorized long stretches. She tried to memorize the entire book. Even today, she recalls where specific Ahs! were penciled into her grandfather's copy.
她一遍又一遍地读莫斯·哈特的《第一幕》。她背下了很长的段落。她甚至试图背下整本书。直到今天，她还记得祖父那本书里具体的“啊！”都记在哪些地方。
Because it felt like I was recognizing an old friend. It felt like a familiarity of, oh, I found a home. This guy likes the same home I want. So--
因为它让我感觉像是在认出一位老朋友。那种熟悉感就像是，哦，我找到了家。这家伙喜欢和我想要的同一个家。所以——
These are my people.
这些人是我的同类。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
You don't meet many people who tell you that a book changed their lives. It's an appealing notion, I think, because it's nice to think that our lives could be changed just by an idea, by the vision of the world that happens in a book, instead of what our lives are often changed by-- you know, dumb luck, tragedies, coincidences. Today on our radio program, stories of people whose lives were changed by books.
你遇不到多少人会告诉你一本书改变了他们的人生。我认为这是一个很有吸引力的念头，因为想到我们的人生能被一个想法、被一本书中对世界的愿景所改变，而不是被那些我们常被其改变的东西——你知道，走运、悲剧、巧合——所驱动，这感觉很好。今天在我们的广播节目中，讲述的是那些人生被书籍改变的人们的故事。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in four acts. Act One is called, well, Act One, getting clues about how to live your life from notes scribbled by your dead grandfather in the margins of a book. Act Two, The Family That Reads Together. In this act, the story of how when David Sedaris was a boy, he stumbled upon a dirty book in the woods. It made his sisters view all adults with newfound suspicion. It sent him to the dictionary. Act Three, Roger and Me, and Lewis and Clark, the story of a construction worker, and this question, can your life be changed by a book that you have never seen and have not read? Act Four, Little Sod Houses For You and Me. It is the old, old story, my friend. New York girl leaves big city, heads out to a small town on the prairie with a dream and a bonnet. Stay with us.
这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕叫作《第一幕》，内容是从你已故祖父在书页空白处的潦草笔记中，获取关于如何过好人生的线索。第二幕，《爱读书的家庭》。在这一幕里，讲述大卫·塞达里斯小时候在树林里偶然发现一本黄色小说的故事。这让他的姐妹们开始以一种新的怀疑眼光看待所有成年人。这还让他去翻阅了字典。第三幕，《罗杰和我，以及刘易斯和克拉克》，讲述一名建筑工人的故事，以及这样一个问题：你的人生会被一本你从未见过、也未读过的书改变吗？第四幕，《你我之间的小草房》。这是个古老的故事，朋友们。纽约女孩离开大城市，怀揣梦想和遮阳帽，前往草原上的小镇。请继续收听。
Act One, Act One. So Alexa Junge says that she never meant for Moss Hart's autobiography to be a blueprint for her life, but looking back on the events of the past two decades, that seems to have been the case.
第一幕，《第一幕》。Alexa Junge说她从没想过莫斯·哈特的自传会成为她人生的蓝图，但回顾过去二十年的经历，情况似乎确实如此。
Basically, what I did was, like he did in his life story, I moved to New York. I think I kind of followed him there.
基本上，我做的就是，像他在人生故事里做的那样，我搬到了纽约。我想我算是追随着他来到这里的。
Really? You consciously followed him there. You thought--
真的吗？你是自觉地追随他来到这里的？你觉得——
I don't think it was conscious, but there are so many things that I did that he did. I wasn't as good a-- I mean, he was more sort of-- He could fake it better than I can. But you know, he had to get money at a certain point. He was like, I need money. So he thought, who's the richest person I know? And he wrote a letter to this woman, I think, and then showed up on her doorstep and said, I'm Moss Hart and I have a play, and if you give me money, we'll put it on. And she did.
我不认为这是自觉的，但我做的很多事情和他做的一样。我没有他那么擅长——我是说，他更那种……他比我更会伪装。但你知道，他在某个时刻需要钱。他想，我认识的人里谁最有钱？于是他给那位女士写了封信，我想，然后出现在她家门口说，我是莫斯·哈特，我有个剧本，如果你给我投资，我们就把它排出来。然后她就给了。
Wow.
哇。
Isn't that amazing? And I wrote letters to strangers and said, I'm Alexa and I have a play, and if you fund my play, you can be part of the theater.
这不神奇吗？我也给陌生人写信说，我是Alexa，我有个剧本，如果你为我的剧本提供资金，你就能参与到戏剧中来。
And did that work?
那成功了吗？
It did one time. Yeah.
有一次成功了。是的。
At some point, did you start to get a crush on him?
在某个时刻，你开始对他产生爱慕之情了吗？
Yeah. It definitely turned from kind of a mentor, a make-believe mentor, to a pretend husband-to-be kind of situation. Yeah, somehow I think I decided that time had completely screwed up and sent Moss to Kitty Carlisle, and that if he just hadn't died two years before I was born, then me and Moss might really have had a chance.
是的。它确实从一种导师、假想的导师，变成了一种假装是未来丈夫的情况。是的，不知为何我想我认定是时间搞错了，把莫斯送给了基蒂·卡莱尔，如果他没有在我出生前两年去世，那么我和莫斯可能真的会有机会。
How would this thought manifest itself in daily life? Like, would you be out on dates and just think, hmm, not Moss. He's not Moss.
这种想法如何在日常生活中体现出来呢？比如，你会出去约会，然后心想，嗯，不是莫斯。他不是莫斯。
Yeah.
是的。
Really?
真的？
Yeah, yeah. Well, it would be like, there'd be something missing. It just wasn't quite what you'd want. And it was like, why can't I find some guy and we'll work on this play together and we'll be, like, in out-of-town tryouts in Philadelphia, and we'll be up for 48 hours trying to fix our play, and then we'll crack it, and then we'll order room service?
是啊，是啊。就会觉得，有些东西缺失了。它就是不像你想要的那样。就像是，为什么我找不到某个家伙和我一起打磨剧本，我们会在费城进行外地试演，为了修改剧本彻夜奋战48小时，然后我们成功了，最后再叫客房服务呢？
So how far did the whole thing go?
那整件事发展到了什么地步？
Well, I think, maybe right before the end of college, Kitty Carlisle spoke one evening.
嗯，我想，大概是在大学毕业前夕，基蒂·卡莱尔有天晚上发表了演讲。
At your college?
在你们大学？
That's right. She was very active in the New York arts scene, and she was extremely a huge advocate of the arts in our country. And so she was talking about that, I think. And I stood in line after she spoke to meet her. And there were all these people around me, and they were like, you were really good on that game show. And I was just, like, disgusted, like, oh please, she was in A Night at the Opera. She's like a singer. She's not just a game show lady.
没错。她在纽约艺术界非常活跃，并且是国内艺术事业的极力倡导者。所以我想她当时在谈论那个。演讲结束后，我排队去见她。周围都是人，他们说，您在那个游戏节目里表现得真好。我当时觉得，厌恶，就像，拜托，她出演过《歌剧院之夜》。她是一位歌手，不只是个游戏节目的女士。
But by the time I got to the front of the line, and I went up to talk to her, I said what I wanted to say, sort of, which was, you know, Moss changed my life and I moved to New York to be a playwright like him. And I think I said something along the lines of, your husband meant so much to me. And she just looked at me, and she was so elegant and so classy, and she just said, I don't understand, darling. Did you know him? She was just terrified.
但当我排到队伍前面去跟她交谈时，我说了我想说的话，或者说类似的话，那就是，你知道，莫斯改变了我的人生，我搬到纽约就是为了像他一样成为一名剧作家。我想我大概说了类似于“你的丈夫对我意义重大”这样的话。她看着我，她是那么优雅、那么有品位，她只是说，我不明白，亲爱的。你认识他吗？她被吓到了。
Like, really? She looked terrified?
像，真的吗？她看起来很害怕？
Yeah. I think she probably heard some kind of ownership or possessiveness in the way I said your husband meant so much to me, as if I knew him. So I think it was confusing, since she probably could figure out that he probably was dead before I was born.
是的。我想她大概从我说“你的丈夫对我意义重大”的方式里听出了一种归属感或占有欲，好像我认识他一样。所以我认为这很令人困惑，因为她大概能推断出他可能在我出生前就去世了。
But it was disturbing, and I felt terrible. And it made me realize how just far from reality this thing had taken me. And it was just scary to scare her, because she's the person that he loved.
但这很令人不安，我感到糟透了。它让我意识到这件事已经让我偏离现实多远了。吓到她是件很可怕的事，因为她是那个他所爱的人。
But my friend that was with me was really nice, because we walked home afterward, and he was like, eh, don't worry about her. You're much better for Moss than she was. He knew the whole story, too.
但我同行的朋友真的很贴心，因为我们后来走路回家时，他说，诶，别担心她。你比她更适合莫斯。他也知道整个故事。
Eh, Moss was just spending time with her because she happened to be alive. You know, you talked about how you felt fated for him in some way, and drawn to him in some way. Have you thought about what is the line that divides that kind of dreamy, healthy feeling, I think, from a scary, stalky feeling?
诶，莫斯只是因为她恰好活着才和她在一起。你知道，你谈到你觉得以某种方式与他命中注定，并被他吸引。你有没有想过，什么才是区分那种梦幻、健康的感受和可怕的跟踪狂感觉的分界线？
Yeah sure, because the truth is, really, the way he functioned in my life was like as a comfort. And I knew. I mean, it wasn't a break from reality, but it was the sense that, when you read a book and something speaks to you and you feel understood, and so it makes the world a less lonely place.
当然，因为事实是，他在我生命中发挥的作用确实是一种慰藉。我知道。我的意思是，这并不是脱离现实，而是一种感觉：当你读一本书，有些东西触动了你，你觉得被理解了，所以这让世界变得不再那么孤独。
Alexa, how much of your feeling about Moss is connected to your feeling about your grandfather, who you didn't really know?
Alexa，你对莫斯的感情有多少是和你对你祖父的感情联系在一起的？毕竟你并不是很了解他。
I think they're intimately connected. I really do. I think that, because I didn't know my grandfather, I couldn't talk to him about what his life in the theater was like. And so this book gave me 444 pages of what it would be like to want to be in the theater and how you might try to make that happen. And so it was like he was the sort of stand-in for my grandfather in a lot of ways.
我想它们是紧密相连的。真的。我认为，因为我不了解我的祖父，我没法和他谈论他在戏剧界的生活是什么样的。所以这本书给了我444页关于想要进入戏剧界会是什么样子，以及你可能如何尝试去实现它的内容。所以从很多方面来看，他就像是我祖父的替身。
And the other part about it is that the way people talk about him-- because I then, of course, went and read every single book I could get my hands on about him, or that even had any mention of him in it-- is with such love and appreciation and affection. It's just staggering. I think that that was how people spoke about my grandfather. And I recognized it, that same enthusiasm and sort of the way their eyes would light up.
另一部分是，人们谈论他的方式——因为我后来当然跑去读了所有我能找到的关于他的书，甚至是任何提到过他的书——那是带着如此多的爱、欣赏和感情。简直令人震惊。我认为这就是人们谈论我祖父的方式。我认出来了，那是同样的狂热，以及人们谈起他时眼神亮起来的样子。
Today, before our interview, you faxed over to our offices here at WBEZ a-- I'm going to pull it out here-- a letter that your grandfather wrote in 1969, obviously as he was quite ill. And it does have this quality of just-- It's one of the most beautifully written things I've ever read.
今天，在我们采访前，你传真到我们WBEZ办公室一封——我把它拿出来——一封你祖父在1969年写下的信，显然当时他病得很重。它有一种……这是我读过写得最美的文章之一。
Isn't it? It's really something.
是吗？确实很有分量。
He spends, I should say most of this thing, he starts off-- this is to his students, right?
他花了，我应该说这封信的大部分，他开头写着——这是写给他的学生的，对吧？
Mmm-hmm. yep.
嗯，是的。
"Dear friends"-- and he says, "I've asked Donald Davis"-- who I would assume was one of his students.
“亲爱的朋友们”——他说，“我请求唐纳德·戴维斯”——我假设这是他的学生之一。
One of his coworkers. Yeah.
他的同事之一。是的。
Coworkers, OK. --"to read this to you. It's intended to tell you as much as I know about my present situation, and thereby, of course, to let you know what the prospects are for the future of the work we've begun together. In planning this letter in my mind, I've been pulled this way and that by very conflicting impulses. I prefer to consider any of my own sickness, any deep trouble, as a very personal matter, possibly to be shared with close members of our family, but never to be inflicted on anyone else. At the same time, I detest mysteries. And those of you who have called have, I hope, been told the truth, insofar as we knew it. But the truth has been shifting, sometimes very swiftly. And what you may have heard a few weeks back is now untrue."
同事，好的。——“来为你们朗读这封信。目的是告知你们我目前的处境，从而，当然，让你们了解我们共同开始的工作未来的前景。在构思这封信时，我被非常冲突的冲动拉扯着。我倾向于将我自己的病痛、任何深刻的苦难视为私事，可能与我们家人的亲密成员分享，但绝不强加给其他人。与此同时，我憎恶神秘。你们当中打过电话的人，我希望都已经获知了真相，就我们所知范围而言。但真相一直在变，有时非常迅速。你们几周前可能听到的事情现在已经不是真相了。”
And then he has this really pretty paragraph. He says, "Besides, though some of you are relatively recent friends, some of our common ties go years back. And old friends or new, the depth of my feeling for you obliges me to be entirely honest with you. And so I'm going to put the next several paragraphs in parentheses, and I'm asking Donald not to read them aloud. Each of you who wishes to can read it for himself. Anyone who dislikes these semi-clinical details can avoid them."
然后他有一段写得真美。他说：“况且，尽管你们有些人是新近的朋友，但我们之间有些共同的纽带可以追溯到多年前。无论新友旧交，我对你们深厚的感情促使我必须对你们完全诚实。所以，我打算把接下来的几段话放在括号里，并请求唐纳德不要朗读它们。任何想读的人都可以自己去读。任何讨厌这些半临床细节的人都可以跳过它们。”
And then there are a couple paragraphs that basically describe the state of his illness. And then he talks about the prognosis, which is not very good, in through another few paragraphs, and then into this last paragraph. Why don't you read that.
然后有几段基本上描述了他病情的状况。然后他谈到了预后，情况不太乐观，接下来的几段话一直到最后这一段。你读读那段吧。
Sure. "Doubtless, all of that sounds very gloomy. I do admit I could think of happier matters. For one thing, I don't at all approve of my own extinction. I don't like the idea of it one bit. Though reason assures me that the world can get along very nicely without me, I can't quite believe that it will. Still, there are a few small compensations. For one thing, I had always hoped that I could face my own death with some equanimity, but it's a bit of a satisfaction to find that I can."
好的。“毫无疑问，这一切听起来很阴沉。我承认我本可以想想更快乐的事情。一方面，我根本不赞同我自己的消亡。我一点也不喜欢这个主意。虽然理性向我保证，没有我世界也能过得很好，但我还是不太能相信会是这样。不过，还是有一些小的补偿。首先，我一直希望我能以某种从容的态度面对自己的死亡，但发现我确实能做到，这本身就是一种满足。”
And then he talks about my mom and my grandmother. And it says, "And that's really what I'm finally wanting to say. I think you're a great bunch. And in case there isn't a chance to say it again, thanks for your concern, your calls, your notes, but above all for your love. You've had my love and I've had yours, and I'm a damn fortunate man. So thanks and good luck. Marvin Borowsky."
然后他谈到了我妈妈和祖母。信中写道：“这就是我最终想说的。我认为你们是一群很棒的人。以防万一没机会再说一次，感谢你们的关心、电话、纸条，但最重要的是，感谢你们的爱。你们得到了我的爱，我也得到了你们的爱，我是一个该死幸运的人。所以，谢谢，祝好运。马文·博罗夫斯基。”
And so this to you feels very much like Hart, too, Moss Hart.
所以这对你来说感觉也非常像哈特，莫斯·哈特。
Yeah. Like, guys who said, I'm a damn fortunate man, you're a swell kid. Yeah.
是的。就像那些会说“我是一个该死幸运的人，你是个很棒的孩子”的家伙。是的。
After a few years in New York, Alexa Junge moved to Los Angeles, as her grandfather did, to write screenplays for Hollywood. Most recently, she was one of the executive producers for the TV show Friends.
在纽约待了几年后，Alexa Junge像她祖父一样搬到了洛杉矶，为好莱坞写剧本。最近，她是电视剧《老友记》的执行制片人之一。
Act Two, The Family That Reads Together. Sometimes a book can change your life, but just in a small, temporary way, and not for the better. We have this cautionary tale about how a book infected an entire family from writer David Sedaris. A quick warning to listeners before we begin, some of the content of this story might not be suitable for every listener, though there is no graphic language, no nasty words, no graphic scenes, nothing, in fact, we even had to bleep.
第二幕，《爱读书的家庭》。有时一本书可以改变你的人生，但只是以一种微小、短暂的方式，而且并非为了变得更好。我们有这样一个关于一本书如何感染整个家庭的警示故事，来自作家大卫·塞达里斯。在开始之前给听众一个简短的警告，这个故事里的某些内容可能不适合所有听众，虽然没有露骨的语言，没有肮脏的词汇，没有色情场景，事实上，我们甚至还要对一些内容消音。
I found the book hidden in the woods beneath a sheet of plywood, its cover torn away and the pages damp with mildew. I read, "Brock and Bonnie Rivers stood in their driveway, waving goodbye to the Reverend Hassleback. 'Goodbye,' they said, waving. 'Goodbye,' the reverend responded. 'Tell those two teens of yours, Josh and Sandi, that they'll make an excellent addition to our young persons' ministry. They're fine kids,' he said with a wink. 'Almost as fine and foxy as their parents.' The Rivers chuckled, raising their hands in another wave. When the reverend's car finally left the driveway, they stood for a moment in the bright sunshine before descending into the basement dungeon to unshackle the children."
我发现这本书藏在树林里一块胶合板下面，封面被撕掉了，页面受潮发霉。我读到：“布洛克和邦妮·里弗斯站在车道上，向哈塞尔贝克牧师挥手告别。‘再见，’他们一边挥手一边说。‘再见，’牧师回应道。‘告诉你们的那两个孩子，乔什和桑迪，他们将成为我们青年事工的出色成员。他们是好孩子，’他眨了眨眼说。‘和他们的父母一样出色、迷人。’里弗斯夫妇轻声笑着，挥手回应。当牧师的车终于离开车道时，他们在明亮的阳光下站了一会儿，然后走进地下室的监牢，解开了孩子们的锁链。”
The theme of the book was that people are not always what they seem. Highly respected in their upper-middleclass community, the Rivers family practiced a literal interpretation of the phrase "Love thy neighbor." Limber as gymnasts, these people were both shameless and insatiable. Father and daughter, brother and sister, mother and son, after exhausting every possible combination, they widened their circle to include horny sea captains and door-to-door knife salesmen. Yes, these people were naughty, but at the age of 13, I couldn't help but admire their infectious energy and spirited enjoyment of life.
这本书的主题是，人们并不总是他们看起来的那样。里弗斯一家在他们的中上层社区备受尊重，却践行着“爱邻如己”这句话的字面意思。这些人的身体像体操运动员一样灵活，既无耻又贪婪。父亲和女儿，哥哥和妹妹，母亲和儿子，在尝试过所有可能的组合后，他们扩大了圈子，包括了饥渴的海员和挨家挨户推销刀具的推销员。是的，这些人很淘气，但在13岁时，我不禁钦佩他们那富有感染力的活力和对生活的热情享受。
The first few times I read the book, I came away shocked, not by the characters' behavior, but by the innumerable typos. Had nobody bothered to proofread this book before sending it to print? In the opening chapter, the daughter is caught fondling her brother's ceck in the dining room. On page 33, the son has sex with his mother, who we are told possesses a fond par of tots. I showed the book to my sister Lisa, who tore it from my hands, saying, let me hold on to this for a while.
前几次读这本书时，我感到震惊，不是因为角色的行为，而是因为书中无数的错别字。难道在付印之前没人费心校对吗？在第一章，女儿在餐厅里被发现抚摸她哥哥的那个部位。第33页，儿子和母亲发生了性关系，书中说母亲拥有“一对迷人的宝贝”。我把这本书给姐姐丽莎看，她从我手中抢走，说，让我保管一阵子。
She and I often swapped babysitting jobs and considered ourselves fairly well read in the field of literary pornography. "Look in the parents' bedroom beneath the sweaters in the second drawer of the white dresser," she'd say. We'd each read The Story of O and the collected writings of the Marquis de Sade with one eye on the front door, fearful that the homeowners might walk in and torture us with barbed whips and hot oils. We know you, our looks would say as the parents checked on their sleeping children. We know all about you.
她和我经常交换看孩子的工作，并认为我们在文学色情领域算得上博览群书。“去父母卧室白梳妆台第二个抽屉里的毛衣下面找找，”她会说。我们每个人都读过《O的故事》和萨德侯爵的文集，一只眼睛盯着前门，害怕房主可能会走进来，用带刺的鞭子和热油折磨我们。我们的眼神仿佛在说，我们知道你们，当父母检查他们睡着的孩子时。我们什么都知道。
The book went from Lisa to our 11-year-old sister, Gretchen, who interpreted it as a startling nonfiction expose on the American middle class. "I'm pretty sure this exact same thing is going on right here in North Hills," she whispered, tucking the book beneath the artificial grass of her Easter basket. "Take the Sherman family, for example. Just last week, I saw Heidi sticking her hands down Steve Junior's pants." "The guy has two broken arms," I said. "She was probably just tucking in his shirt." "Would you ask one of us to tuck in your shirt?" she asked. She had a point. A careful study suggested that the Shermans were not the people they pretended to be. The father was often seen tugging at his crotch, and the wife had a disturbing habit of looking you straight in the eye while sniffing her fingers. A veil had been lifted, especially for Gretchen, who now saw the world as a steaming pit of unbridled sexuality.
这本书从丽莎传到了我们11岁的妹妹格雷琴手中，她将其解读为一篇关于美国中产阶级的惊人非虚构揭秘。“我很确定这种事就在北山这里发生，”她低声说，把书塞进她复活节篮子的人造草下面。“拿谢尔曼一家举例。就在上周，我看见海蒂把手伸进了小史蒂夫的裤子里。”“那家伙两只手都骨折了，”我说。“她可能只是在帮他掖衬衫。”“你会叫我们帮你掖衬衫吗？”她问。她说的有道理。仔细研究表明，谢尔曼一家并不是他们表现出的那样。父亲常被看到抓挠裆部，妻子有一种令人不安的习惯，一边直视着你，一边嗅着自己的手指。一层面纱被揭开了，尤其是对格雷琴来说，她现在把世界看作一个毫无节制的性欲沸腾的深渊。
Seated on a lounge chair at the country club, she would narrow her eyes, speculating on the children crowding the shallow end of the pool. "I have a sneaking suspicion Christina Youngblood might be our half sister," she said. "She's got her father's chin, but the eyes and mouth are pure Mom." I felt uneasy implicating our parents, but Gretchen provided a wealth of frightening evidence. She noted the way our mother applied lipstick at the approach of the potato chip delivery man, whom she addressed by first name and often invited in to use the bathroom. Our father referred to the bank tellers as "doll" and "sweetheart," and their responses suggested that he had taken advantage of them one time too many.
坐在乡村俱乐部的休闲椅上，她会眯起眼睛，盯着游泳池浅水区里聚集的孩子们。“我有个惊人的怀疑，克里斯蒂娜·杨布拉德可能是我们同父异母的姐妹，”她说。“她有她父亲的下巴，但眼睛和嘴巴纯粹是我们妈的。”我觉得把我们的父母牵扯进来令人不安，但格雷琴提供了大量令人恐惧的证据。她注意到母亲在薯片送货员走近时涂口红的方式，母亲直呼对方的名字，还经常邀请他进去用洗手间。父亲把银行出纳员称为“小可爱”和“甜心”，她们的反应表明他占她们的便宜已经不止一次了。
The Greek Orthodox church, the gaily dressed couples at the country club, even our elderly collie, Duchess, they were all in on it according to Gretchen, who took to piling furniture against her bedroom door before going to sleep at night. The book wound up in the hands of our 10-year-old sister, Amy, who used it as a textbook in the make-believe class she held after school each day. Dressed in a wig and high heels, she passed her late afternoons standing before a blackboard and imitating her teachers.
希腊东正教教堂、乡村俱乐部里衣着光鲜的夫妇们，甚至我们那条上了年纪的柯利犬公爵夫人，根据格雷琴的说法，他们都参与其中，她开始在睡觉前把家具堆在卧室门口。这本书最后落到了我们10岁的妹妹艾米手里，她把它当作课本，在每天放学后举办的假想课堂上使用。她戴着假发，穿着高跟鞋，下午晚些时候站在黑板前模仿她的老师。
"I'm very sorry, Candice, but I'm going to have to fail you," she'd say, addressing one of the empty folding chairs arranged before her. "The problem is not that you don't try. The problem is that you're stupid, very, very stupid. Isn't Candice stupid, class? She's ugly, too. Am I wrong? Very well, Candice, you can sit back down now. And for god's sakes, please stop crying. OK, class. Now I'm going to read to you from this week's new book. It's a story about a California family and it's called Next of Kin. "
“我很抱歉，坎迪斯，但我不得不让你不及格，”她会对准放在面前的一把空折叠椅说。“问题不在于你不努力。问题在于你很蠢，非常、非常蠢。同学们，坎迪斯是不是很蠢？她也很丑。我错了吗？好吧，坎迪斯，你可以坐回去了。看在上帝的份上，请别再哭了。好了，同学们。现在我要读这周的新书。这是一个关于加州家庭的故事，书名是《近亲》。”
If Amy had read the book, then surely it had been seen by eight-year-old Tiffany, who shared her bedroom, and possibly by our brother, Paul, who at the age of two might have sucked on the binding, which was even more dangerous than reading it. Clearly, this had to stop before it got out of hand. Even our ancient Greek grandmother was arriving at the breakfast table with suspicious-looking circles beneath her eyes.
如果艾米读过这本书，那么肯定也被8岁的蒂芙尼看见过，她和艾米住一间房，甚至可能被我们2岁的弟弟保罗看见，他可能吮吸过装订处，这比阅读更危险。显然，这在失控前必须停止。连我们那位古希腊祖母早餐时眼眶下都带着令人怀疑的黑眼圈。
Gretchen took the book and hid it under the carpet of her bedroom, where it was discovered by our housekeeper, Lena, who eventually handed it over to our mother. "I'll make sure this is properly disposed of," my mother said, hurrying down the hallway to her bedroom. "Panetration," she laughed, reading out loud from a randomly selected page. "Oh, this ought to be good."
格雷琴拿走书把它藏在卧室地毯下，后来被我们的管家莉娜发现，最终交到了母亲手中。“我会确保它被妥善处理，”母亲说，匆匆走下走廊回到卧室。“插入，”她大声念着，选了随机一页，“哦，这应该很棒。”
Weeks later, Gretchen and I found the book hidden between the mattress and box springs of my parents' bed, the pages stained with coffee rings and cigarette ash. The discovery seemed to validate all of Gretchen's suspicions. "They'll be coming for us any day now," she warned. "Be prepared, my friend, because this time they'll be playing for keeps." We waited. I'd always made it a point to kiss my mother before going to bed, but not anymore. The feel of her hand on my shoulder now made my flesh crawl.
几周后，格雷琴和我在父母床的床垫和弹簧箱之间发现了这本书，书页上沾着咖啡渍和烟灰。这一发现似乎证实了格雷琴所有的怀疑。“他们随时都会来找我们，”她警告说。“做好准备，我的朋友，因为这次他们是玩真的。”我们等着。我以前总是习惯在睡前亲吻母亲，但现在不会了。她放在我肩膀上的手的触感现在让我毛骨悚然。
She was hemming a pair of my pants one afternoon when, standing before her on a kitchen chair, I felt her hands grace my butt. "I-- I just want to be friends," I stammered. "Nothing more, nothing less." She took the pins out of her mouth and studied me for a moment before sighing. "Damn, and here you've been leading me on all this time."
一天下午她正在缝我的裤子，我站在厨房的椅子上，感觉到她的手抚摸着我的屁股。“我——我只是想做朋友，”我结结巴巴地说。“仅此而已，别无他念。”她从嘴里拿出大头针，盯着我看了片刻，叹了口气。“该死，原来你一直是在引诱我。”
I read the book once more, hoping to recapture my earlier pleasure, but it was too late now. I couldn't read the phrase, "He paunched his daughter's rock-hard nopples," without thinking of Gretchen barricading herself in the bedroom. I thought I might throw the book away, or maybe even burn it, but like a perfectly good outgrown sweater, it seemed a shame to destroy it when the world was full of people who might get some use out of it.
我再读了一遍那本书，希望能找回当初的乐趣，但现在太晚了。我无法阅读“他抚摸着女儿坚硬的乳头”这个短语，而不想到格雷琴在卧室里把自己路障起来的样子。我想我可能会扔掉它，或者干脆烧了它，但就像一件很棒但已经穿不下的毛衣，既然世界上有很多人可能会从中受益，毁掉它似乎太可惜了。
With this in mind, I carried the book to the grocery store parking lot, and tossed it into the back of a shiny new pickup truck. I then took up my post beside the store's outdoor vending machines, waiting until the truck's owner returned, pushing a cart full of groceries. He was a wiry man, with fashionable mutton-chop sideburns and a half-cast on his arm.
想到这，我把书带到了杂货店停车场，扔进了一辆崭新的皮卡车后座。然后我在店外的自动售货机旁守着，等车主回来，他推着一车杂货。那是一个精干的男人，长着时尚的羊排胡，手臂上打着半个石膏。
As he placed his bags into the back of the truck, his eyes narrowed upon the book. I watched as he picked it up and leafed through the first few pages, before raising his head to search the parking lot. He took a cigarette from his pocket and tapped it against the roof of the truck before lighting it. Then he slipped the book into his pocket and drove away.
当他把袋子放进卡车后座时，他的目光落在书上。我看着他捡起书，翻看了前几页，然后抬起头搜寻停车场。他从口袋里掏出一根香烟，在卡车顶上敲了敲，然后点燃。接着他把书塞进兜里，开车走了。
David Sedaris is the author of several books, including Naked, in which this story appears. Coming up, the frontier then and then. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
大卫·塞达里斯是包括《裸体》在内的多本书的作者，这个故事就收录其中。接下来，边疆往事。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台节目继续播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, The Book That Changed My Life. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Roger and Me, Lewis and Clark. There's book as literature, there's book as filth, and then there's book as pure physical object. This is the story of somebody for whom a book changed his life, though it is almost random that it happened at all, that he got to know this book in the first place. Jeremy Goldstein tells the story.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《改变我人生的书》。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《罗杰和我，以及刘易斯和克拉克》。有作为文学的书，有作为污秽物的书，还有作为纯粹物理对象的书。这是一个人的故事，书改变了他的人生，尽管这纯属偶然。Jeremy Goldstein讲述了这个故事。
Roger was 34, working in construction and looking for things to do in his spare time. And one day, he noticed this plate he'd been given by his grandmother, a plate from a 1905 fair celebrating the centennial of Lewis and Clark's expedition to explore the Western frontier. He looked at the plate and wondered if there was anything else left from the fair still around. It turned out there was a lot, and he started buying it up.
罗杰今年34岁，从事建筑工作，在空闲时间寻找消遣。有一天，他注意到祖母给他的一个盘子，那是1905年纪念刘易斯和克拉克探索西部边疆百年纪念博览会的盘子。他看着盘子，心想博览会是否还有其他东西留下来。事实证明有很多，他开始疯狂购买。
It was a fun hobby, collecting the various memorabilia from that fair. But when you reach a point where I had about 1,100 items, one of the larger collections known, it was the end of the treasure hunt. And I couldn't find anything I didn't have. And somebody mentioned, well, why don't you collect books about Lewis and Clark? I thought, well, that might be kind of fun to do.
收集博览会上的各种纪念品是一种有趣的爱好。但当你像我一样拥有大约1100件物品，成为已知最大的收藏之一时，寻宝也就到头了。我再也找不到我没有的东西了。有人提到，嗯，你为什么不收集关于刘易斯和克拉克的书呢？我想，嗯，那可能挺有趣的。
So in 1984, he went to a book dealer in Vancouver, and picked out an 80-year-old set of books that chronicled Lewis and Clark's expedition. The price? $695.
所以1984年，他去温哥华的一家书店，选购了一套记录刘易斯和克拉克远征的80年历史的书。价格？695美元。
I had a difficult time writing out that check, because at that time, in fact, I really didn't know much about books. I proceeded to take that set of books downtown in Portland, to an established book dealer whose name was Preston McMann. And I showed him the set. I said, well, that's it, isn't it? That's all the journals. And he kind of chuckled. He said, no, there's a lot more publications than that about the journals of Lewis and Clark. And so I went ahead and said, well, I tell you what. I said, you give me about five years, I'm going to have every book published about Lewis and Clark. And he laughed so hard, he about laughed himself out of his chair.
开那张支票时我费了很大劲，因为那时候，事实上，我对书真的一无所知。我带着那套书去了波特兰市中心，找了一位知名书商，名叫Preston McMann。我给他展示了这套书。我说，好吧，就是这个了，对吧？这就是所有的日记。他轻声笑了。他说，不，关于刘易斯和克拉克日记的出版物还有很多。于是我继续说，好吧，我告诉你怎么着。我说，你给我大约五年时间，我会有每一本关于刘易斯和克拉克的书。他笑得那么大声，差点从椅子上摔下来。
He was a heavyset gentleman in his late 60s at the time. And he said, there's people that have spent lifetimes looking for every book of Lewis and Clark and have never succeeded. Well, I told him, well, maybe I won't have every book, but I'll have the best library of anybody in the United States. And he laughed harder.
他当时是一位60多岁身材魁梧的绅士。他说，有人花了一辈子寻找每一本关于刘易斯和克拉克的书，但从未成功。好吧，我告诉他，好吧，也许我不会有每一本书，但我会拥有全美最好的图书馆。他笑得更厉害了。
Strange as it may sound, this is all it took to send Roger on his path of amassing, in just 14 years, what did become the largest-known private collection of Lewis and Clark books in the United States. And all this time, he kept working in construction, excavating landscapes, laying pipes for sewers and paving roads, a decent living, but it was never enough.
听起来很奇怪，但这足以让罗杰走上积累之路，在短短14年里，他确实成为了全美最大的刘易斯和克拉克私人书库拥有者。这段时间里，他一直在做建筑工，挖掘土地、铺设下水道管道和道路铺设，收入不错，但永远不够。
Anything after house payment and basic expenses for living would go toward buying books. I would have to work 10 to 12 hours a day, normally six days a week, some summers I wouldn't take a day off, just so that I could work and have a little better check so maybe I could get that next book, or make that other credit card payment, because I was now beyond my means.
付完房贷和基本生活费后，剩下的钱都会拿去买书。我通常每天工作10到12小时，一周工作六天，有些夏天我一天都没休息，就是为了能多挣点钱，好去买下一本书，或者还信用卡债，因为我已经入不敷出。
At one point, Roger had 12 credit cards.
有段时间，罗杰有12张信用卡。
And then, of course, I had a house I could refinance, which I did three times. I don't know how to explain it, exactly. But if there was a book out there that I didn't have, I would find the means to acquire it. When you get something of the 18th, 19th century, you open up the book, and you look at the discoloration of the pages, and the smell, and that's when you really feel the true energy of history, not what you would read, but you've got more senses than just your eyes. You can smell. You can feel. You can touch.
然后，当然，我有一套房子可以抵押贷款，我抵押了三次。我不知道该怎么解释。但如果外面有一本我没有的书，我总能找到办法弄到手。当你拿到18、19世纪的东西，打开书，看着变色的书页，闻着那股味道，那就是你真正感受到历史能量的时候，不是你读到的东西，而是你有多种感官，不仅仅是眼睛。你可以闻，可以摸，可以触碰。
This actually points to one of the strangest things about Roger's relationship with his collection. He knew all about the different Lewis and Clark books, marbled endpapers, obscure hand-tinted plates, and the value of original boards. But Roger never became an expert on what was inside the books. He didn't collect books to read them. He just wanted to own them. It turns out that your life can be changed by books you didn't even read.
这实际上指出了罗杰与他的藏书之间最奇怪的一点。他对各种刘易斯和克拉克书籍的装帧细节、大理石扉页、晦涩的手工上色图版以及原版书板的价值了如指掌。但罗杰从来没有成为书本内容的专家。他收藏书不是为了读。他只是想拥有它们。事实证明，你的人生会被你甚至没读过的书改变。
In fact, Roger had never been a reader of books. He didn't read books as a kid. He didn't go to college. And his reading habits didn't change as an adult, when his house was full of books. As a collector, Roger was undeterred and he was methodical. But after 10 years, one book still eluded him. It's the cornerstone of any serious Lewis and Clark collection, a first edition copy of the first official account of the expedition. It's a two-volume set published in 1814. Fewer than 1,500 copies were ever printed. But the price tag, often around $10,000, had always scared Roger off. Then in 1994, he took a $49 flight to Los Angeles for the LA book fair.
事实上，罗杰从来不是个爱读书的人。他小时候不读书。他没上过大学。当他房子里装满书时，他的阅读习惯也没有改变。作为一名收藏家，罗杰毫不动摇且井井有条。但在10年后，还有一本书一直令他魂牵梦绕。它是任何严肃的刘易斯和克拉克收藏的基石，是远征队第一次官方记录的初版副本。这是一套1814年出版的两卷本。印数不到1500册。但高达1万美元左右的价格一直让罗杰望而却步。然后在1994年，他花49美元飞往洛杉矶参加LA书展。
That particular day, I got there early. And then there was somewhat of a race when they opened up the gate. They would actually have to stand, slow down, slow down, don't run. It was like kids running for the opening of a carnival. I sauntered just casually, I didn't run, to William Reese's booth, and introduced myself. Oh yeah, Hi Roger.
那天我到得很早。开门时有一场赛跑。他们实际上不得不站住，慢点，慢点，别跑。就像孩子们跑向嘉年华开幕一样。我随意地溜达着，没跑，走到威廉·里斯的展位，做了自我介绍。哦对了，嘿，罗杰。
And I says, did you bring anything about Lewis and Clark with you? And he turned and looked toward the glass case, and there sits a two-volume set of 1814 Lewis and Clark journals. And this set was beautiful. And I was just shaking. I wanted the set so bad. And I looked at him and I says, what's the price? Bill said, $12,500. I was crushed. I knew it was beyond me.
我说，你带了关于刘易斯和克拉克的书吗？他转过身看着玻璃展柜，里面放着一套两卷本的1814年刘易斯和克拉克日记。这套书太美了。我浑身发抖。我太想要这套书了。我看着他说，多少钱？比尔说，12500美元。我崩溃了。我知道我买不起。
So as I kind of backed away and started to walk away from the booth, just knowing, shaking my head to myself, I can't afford them, there's no way I can get-- I've got to have this set of books, somehow I've gotta-- I can't afford these books, I can't, there's no way, I gotta have this set of books, how the hell can I do it, geez, I better go to the bar. I walked to the bar, got a shot of scotch.
所以我一边向后退，一边走开，心里摇着头，我买不起，我根本没法——我必须拥有这套书，不管怎样我得——我买不起这些书，我买不起，没门，但我必须拥有这套书，到底该怎么办呢，天哪，我最好去喝一杯。我走向吧台，喝了一杯苏格兰威士忌。
I walked back to the booth with my scotch in hand, and I says, can I look at those again? And Bill, yeah, sure. Took them off the shelf, set them on the counter. He says, well, Roger, what can you afford? I says, I don't know. I says, we're not working. This is a slow time of the year. I might be able to do $1,000 a month. But ah, Bill, you know, we're not working now. I don't know, maybe in May or June. You know, when we start working overtime.
我拿着威士忌回到展位说，我能再看一眼吗？比尔说，好的，当然。他把书从架子上拿下来，放在柜台上。他说，罗杰，你能负担多少？我说，我不知道。我说，我们现在没开工。现在是淡季。我可能每个月能出1000美元。但啊，比尔，你知道，我们现在不开工。我不知道，也许五月或六月吧。你知道，等我们开始加班的时候。
And he said, well, do you want them? And I said, yeah, but, gosh, I can't-- And before I could finish the conversation, Mr. Reese had turned around and took these books, put them in the bag, wrapped them up, turned around, put out his hand and shook my hand and said, that sounds good enough to me.
他说，那你想要吗？我说，想要，但是，天哪，我不能——我还没说完，里斯先生已经转过身，拿起这些书，放进袋子里，打包好，转过身，伸出手跟我握手说，这听起来对我来说已经够好了。
The 1814 became Roger's calling card. It established him as an expert in all things written about Lewis and Clark. And then something happened. Roger started to read his books. Before this, he'd occasionally pull out a book and read a random passage, but now he started to plow through whole books front to back.
这套1814年的书成了罗杰的名片。它确立了他作为刘易斯和克拉克相关一切事物专家的地位。然后发生了一件事。罗杰开始读他的书了。在此之前，他偶尔会抽出一本书读一段，但现在他开始从头到尾仔细啃读整本书。
Now it's my time to study the books. Let's look at this book that's in front of me. I've got it open to-- just by chance-- a passage that brings a lot of pleasure to me, is the fact that--
现在是我研究这些书的时候了。看看摆在我面前的这本书。我随便翻到了一页——纯属巧合——有一段让我倍感愉悦，事实是——
The passage comes about halfway through the expedition. After 18 months of looking for a route to the ocean, they finally reach the Pacific.
这段文字出现在远征行程过半时。在寻找通往海洋的路线18个月后，他们终于抵达了太平洋。
And here they finally-- "We are in view of the ocean, this great Pacific ocean, which we have so long anxious to see. The roaring and the noise made by the waves breaking on the rocky shores may be heard distinctly. Ocean in view! O! The joy!" So in this passage, place yourself on the banks of the Columbia River, looking out toward the ocean. I mean, I'd be jumping up and down screaming, where is that gill of whiskey? Which they didn't have at that time, unfortunately. I mean, they would have taken a gallon and all chugged it, and they'd have just been sloshed on the banks and just partyin' forever. I mean, it's great. What a feeling of success. It just brings a great pleasure myself. "Ocean in view! O! The joy!"
在这里他们终于——“我们看到了海洋，这片伟大的太平洋，我们渴望已久的海洋。岩岸边海浪拍打的咆哮声和轰鸣声清晰可闻。海洋在望！哦！真叫人高兴！”所以在这段里，想象自己站在哥伦比亚河岸边，望着大海。我的意思是，我会高兴得跳起来大喊，那杯威士忌在哪里？遗憾的是当时他们没有。我的意思是，他们本可以拿出一加仑大口畅饮，然后喝得大醉，在河岸上狂欢不止。我的意思是，太棒了。那种成功的感觉。这本身就给我带来了巨大的快乐。“海洋在望！哦！真叫人高兴！”
Last week, Roger made a pilgrimage of sorts to see, for the first time, the original handwritten journals that Lewis and Clark kept during their expedition. They're the books that everything Roger ever bought are descended from. Most of the journals are stored at the American Philosophical Society in Philadelphia. They're in remarkable condition. As a librarian turned the books crisp pages for Roger, flipping past detailed maps and intricate drawings of animals, Roger barely moved or spoke.
上周，罗杰进行了一次朝圣，第一次亲眼看到了刘易斯和克拉克在远征期间保留的原始手写日记。它们就是罗杰买的所有书籍的源头。大多数日记保存在费城的美国哲学学会。它们保存状态良好。当图书管理员为罗杰翻开这些清脆的书页，掠过详尽的地图和动物的复杂图纸时，罗杰几乎没动，也没说话。
Lewis and Clark's map of Great Falls of the Columbia. And you're seeing it upside-down, the Columbia.
刘易斯和克拉克的哥伦比亚大瀑布地图。你看到的是倒着的，哥伦比亚河。
At one point, Roger asked, could he touch them? He was told no. And after less than an hour with the journals, we wandered back into the library's main reading room.
有一次，罗杰问，他能摸摸它们吗？得到的回答是不行。和日记相处不到一小时后，我们回到图书馆的主阅览室。
The book has altered my life from being a manual labor to being a scholar of knowledge from the interior of the book. Stephen Beckham, a professor at Lewis & Clark, once said, well, Roger, you can't put yourself down for being a construction foreman. He said, that's a school of another type. He says, I love school and I love education. And he says, and now that you're entering that field with us, I have great respect for what you've done and what you know. And it makes me feel great.
书改变了我的人生，让我从一名体力劳动者变成了书本知识的学者。刘易斯与克拉克学院的教授史蒂芬·贝克汉姆曾说，好吧，罗杰，你不能因为自己是工头就贬低自己。他说，那是另一种学校。他说，我热爱学校，热爱教育。他说，现在你和我们一起进入了这个领域，我非常尊重你所做的一切和你所知道的一切。这让我感觉很棒。
In the years since Roger began collecting, the value of all things Lewis and Clark has soared. Stephen Ambrose wrote a popular book, Undaunted Courage . Ken Burns did a documentary. These fueled the fire. And last fall, Roger arranged for a Lewis & Clark College in Portland to purchase his entire collection for what amounts to a small fortune. He promptly retired from construction at the age of 54.
自从罗杰开始收藏以来，所有刘易斯和克拉克相关藏品的价值都飙升了。史蒂芬·安布罗斯写了畅销书《无畏的勇气》。肯·伯恩斯拍了纪录片。这些都火上浇油。去年秋天，罗杰安排波特兰的刘易斯与克拉克学院购买了他的整个藏品，金额高达一笔小小的财富。他随即以54岁的高龄从建筑行业退休。
I just smiled. I just smiled. And I walked in, sat down, leaned back in the chair, and thought, wow, a whole new life. I don't have an alarm clock now. I mean, I've got one, but it's not in use. When my body says to get up in the morning, I get up. I stretch, do some light exercises, have a nice relaxing breakfast. Any of those in construction industry now listening to this, eat your hearts out.
我只是微笑。我只是微笑着。走进去，坐下，靠在椅子上，心想，哇，全新的人生。我现在不用闹钟了。我的意思是，我有一个，但没在用。当身体告诉我早上该起床时，我就起床。伸个懒腰，做些轻微的运动，吃一顿惬意的早餐。现在正在听这个节目的建筑业同行们，羡慕死你们吧。
Most of Roger's days are now spent in the library of Lewis & Clark college, where Doug Erickson is the chief archivist. Roger's known him for years.
罗杰现在大多数时间都在刘易斯与克拉克学院的图书馆度过，道格·埃里克森是那里的首席档案管理员。罗杰认识他很多年了。
You know, Roger would oftentimes get off of work when he was still working construction, and not even clean up and come over to Lewis and Clark and spend time with me. And we'd chat and talk about books. But he was tired. He was very tired, and he looked like he'd just gone through a hard day of labor on a construction site. Now you see Roger, he strolls in sometime in the morning, whenever he feels like it. He walks in feeling like a king.
你知道，罗杰在做建筑工时，通常下班后甚至不清理自己就跑到刘易斯与克拉克学院来找我。我们会聊天，谈论书籍。但他很累。他非常疲惫，看起来就像刚在工地经历了一天艰苦的体力劳动。现在你见到的罗杰，他有时会在上午溜达进来，随心所欲。他走进来时感觉像个国王。
And then I usually go up to the Heritage Room, and I just sit there and immerse myself into that. And of course, I'm surrounded by the books. It's a wonderful feeling being in there.
然后我通常会去遗产室，沉浸在其中。当然，我被书籍环绕。在那里感觉太美妙了。
And he goes up there and he works. And every couple of-- oh, every hour or two, he'll come down all excited, Doug, you gotta come up here and see this. And I'll come upstairs, and he'll show me something and we'll get excited about it. And as I see him in the Heritage Room for many years to come, writing books and having people coming and talk to him, and just enjoying the rest of his life.
他去上面工作。每隔一阵——哦，每隔一两小时，他就会激动地跑下来，道格，你得上来看看这个。我会上楼，他给我展示些东西，我们对此感到兴奋。未来很多年我都能在遗产室见到他，写书，有人来找他交谈，享受着余生。
That story by Jeremy Goldstein, a television producer in New York City.
那个故事由Jeremy Goldstein提供，他是纽约市的一名电视制作人。
Act Four, Little Sod houses For You and Me. When you really love a book, what exactly are you supposed to do with that feeling after you finish reading the book, and then perhaps finish reading about the book? If you feel strongly enough about the book, I think there is this impulse to somehow get closer to the book, to somehow try and conjure the world of the book right here in the real world somehow. So if you read about a Broadway playwright, maybe you move to New York City and start writing plays. Or if you already live in New York City, but the book takes place somewhere else, you head out there. Meghan Daum has this story.
第四幕，《你我之间的小草房》。当你真正爱上一本书时，读完这本书，也许读完关于这本书的评论后，你到底该如何处理这种感觉呢？如果你对这本书有足够强烈的感觉，我想有一种冲动是想尽可能地接近这本书，试图在现实世界中召唤出书中的世界。所以如果你读的是一位百老汇剧作家，也许你会搬到纽约开始写剧本。或者如果你已经住在纽约，但书中的故事发生在其他地方，你就会前往那里。Meghan Daum有这个故事。
I'm moving to Nebraska. No one understands why. I've lived in New York City for seven years, which is essentially all of my adult life. And a few months ago, I started making plans to head out west, not all the way west to California or Oregon, which people from around here might understand, but to the Great Plains. I wanted to move someplace flat and treeless, some place that gives off a sense of how big this country used to be before automobiles and the jet age, before you could be cavalier about traveling from one place to another.
我要搬到内布拉斯加州。没人理解为什么。我在纽约市住了七年，这基本上是我成年后的全部时光。几个月前，我开始计划向西出发，不是一直向西到加州或俄勒冈，那是住在这附近的人能理解的方向，而是去大平原。我想搬到一个平坦、没有树木的地方，一个能展现汽车和喷气时代之前这个国家有多大的地方，在那之前，你不会对从一个地方旅行到另一个地方表现得那么漫不经心。
There are a lot of reasons behind my move, but one of the reasons has to do with a book, with nine books, as a matter of fact. They're the books written by Laura Ingalls Wilder about her childhood as a pioneer girl on the vast Midwestern prairie in the late 1800s. When I was a little girl growing up nearly 100 years later in the 1970s, I wanted to be like Laura so much that I made my mother sew me a sunbonnet, which I wore constantly.
我搬家背后的原因有很多，但其中一个原因与一本书有关，事实上是九本书。它们是劳拉·英格斯·怀尔德写的，关于她19世纪末作为先驱女孩在广阔的中西部草原上的童年。当我还是个近100年后的1970年代成长的女孩时，我非常想成为劳拉，以至于我让母亲给我缝了一顶遮阳帽，我经常戴着它。
Like Laura, I wore my hair in braids. Before I knew how to write, I drew picture books featuring the entire Ingalls family. It was always a variation on the same theme, a family moves to a new home, encounters hardships, and through a particular combination of self-reliance and hard work, makes a life for themselves in the new place, a place so remote, so unsettled, so cold, that no civilization, not even most Indians, had ever dared to live there.
像劳拉一样，我把头发梳成辫子。在学会写字之前，我就画了以英格斯一家为主角的图画书。主题总是大同小异：一个家庭搬到新家，遇到困难，通过自立和努力工作的结合，在新地方建立起生活，一个如此偏远、如此未开发、如此寒冷的地方，以至于没有任何文明，甚至大多数印第安人，都从未敢住在那里。
To me, this kind of uncharted life was the best kind to have. And it was even better that it required a sunbonnet.
对我来说，这种未知的探索生活是最好的人生。如果还要戴上遮阳帽，那就更好了。
[SOUNDS OF HORSE-DRAWN WAGON]
[马车的马蹄声]
She taught at three schools. The first one was the Brewster School, and that's where Almanzo would take her down and pick her up. It was about 12 miles to the southwest.
她教过三所学校。第一所是布鲁斯特学校，阿尔曼佐会带她去那儿并接她。距离西南方大约12英里。
I'm in De Smet, South Dakota, riding a horse-drawn wagon around the actual land that the Ingalls lived on. Our tour guide is Tim Sullivan. Tim and his wife Joan own the 154 acres of land that Laura's father, Charles Ingalls, claimed in 1880 as part of the Homestead Act.
我在南达科他州的德斯梅特，坐着马车在英格斯一家实际生活过的土地上兜风。我们的导游是蒂姆·沙利文。蒂姆和他的妻子琼拥有劳拉的父亲查尔斯·英格斯在1880年作为《宅地法》一部分申请的154英亩土地。
This is an old trapper's cabin that we're going to fix up. We haven't gotten it done, but that's the only thing we haven't gotten done.
这是一个老猎人的小屋，我们要翻修它。我们还没做完，但这是我们唯一还没做完的事情。
A lot of people think the Ingalls are from Walnut Grove, Minnesota, because that's where the television series was set. But in fact, they only lived there for a few years. Laura came to De Smet in 1879, when she was 12. It was where she grew up, became a school teacher, and met and married Almanzo Wilder. Six of her books are set there.
很多人认为英格斯一家来自明尼苏达州的核桃林，因为电视剧的场景设在那里。但事实上，他们只在那里住了几年。劳拉在1879年来到德斯梅特时，只有12岁。这是她长大的地方，成为小学老师的地方，也是她遇到并嫁给阿尔曼佐·怀尔德的地方。她的六本书都以这里为背景。
For those who remember, it's the place where Laura and her sister, Mary, who was blind, got lost in the tall, wet grasses known as the Big Slough. It's the place where the family survived the long winter, and it was the place she always considered home.
对于记得的人来说，这是劳拉和她失明的姐姐玛丽在被称为大泥沼的高湿草地中迷路的地方。这是全家人度过漫长冬季的地方，也是她一直认为的家。
So when she talks about walking through the cool ground, just walking to prairie school, if you see when we're going home, it's wet there, that's why it would have been cool.
所以当她谈到走在凉爽的土地上，走路去草原学校时，如果你看到我们回家时的样子，那里很湿，这就是为什么它会很凉快。
There's a certain kind of town that is defined solely by one industry, like steel towns, where at least one member of every family works in the mill. De Smet is sort of like that, too, except the industry is a series of books.
有一种小镇完全由单一行业定义，比如钢铁小镇，每个家庭至少有一个人在钢厂工作。德斯梅特也有点类似，只是这个行业是一系列的书。
Every year for the past 29 years, the townspeople have put on a pageant based on Laura's life. Just about everyone in this town of 1,200 has participated in the pageant, or at least had one family member who has put on 1880s-style clothing at one time or another and given tours at the museum, or given some hapless tourist directions to the cemetery, where caravans of family cars wind around the grounds looking for the burial sites of Charles, Caroline, Mary, Carrie, and Grace Ingalls. Almost every establishment in De Smet, even the local bar, has restrooms labeled Ma and Pa.
在过去29年的每一年，镇民们都会举办一场基于劳拉生平的选美游行。这个1200人口小镇的几乎每个人都参与过游行，或者至少有一个家庭成员曾经穿过1880年代风格的服装，在博物馆做过导游，或者给不知所措的游客指过去公墓的路，那里成群的车队在地上盘旋，寻找查尔斯、卡罗琳、玛丽、嘉莉和格蕾丝·英格斯的墓地。德斯梅特的几乎每家机构，甚至当地的酒吧，洗手间都被贴上了“爸爸”和“妈妈”的标签。
But even though De Smet is, for all intents and purposes, a tourist town, it doesn't feel like one. Instead, it feels like a town with a hobby, a place where a lot of people devote a lot of time to one particular idea. The tourists, though they're greeted in that typically warm Midwestern way, feel almost incidental to the larger cause of celebrating Laura.
但尽管德斯梅特实际上是一个旅游城镇，它却感觉不像。相反，它感觉像是一个有爱好的城镇，一个很多人把大量时间致力于一个特定想法的地方。虽然游客们受到了典型的热情中西部式的欢迎，但相对于庆祝劳拉这一更大的事业而言，他们感觉几乎是无关紧要的。
I talked to a man who had acted in the pageant for 27 years, missing only two performances the whole time, one of them because of a combine accident in which he lost his finger, and his son was impaled and almost died. He was back on stage the next night. His wife, Eldina, had driven them to the hospital and witnessed a pretty gory series of medical procedures performed, by the way, without anesthesia. The night of the accident, her husband had one request of her.
我和一个参加了27年游行的人谈过，在此期间他只错过了两次表演，其中一次是因为联合收割机事故，他失去了一个手指，他的儿子被刺穿差点丧命。第二天晚上他又回到了舞台上。他的妻子埃尔迪娜开车送他们去了医院，目睹了一系列相当血腥的医疗程序，顺便说一句，是在没有麻醉的情况下进行的。事故当晚，她丈夫对她提出了一个请求。
He says, honey, you have to go on. I was playing Ma at the time. And so I did perform that night. And I think I was probably in shock myself, because it went fairly well. But it was on Sunday night is where I kind of fell apart. I forgot a few lines, but we made it.
他说，亲爱的，你必须继续。我当时正在扮演妈妈。所以那天晚上我确实表演了。我想我当时可能自己也处于休克状态，因为表演得还算顺利。但周日晚上我有点崩溃了。我忘了几句台词，但我们还是演完了。
Laura's books have a lot to do with the notion of rising to the occasion. And the pageant demands countless hours of volunteer effort, cooperation, and manual labor done without complaint. In a way, this kind of idyllic, romantic work ethic is not what I expected when I came to De Smet. Or I should say it is what I expected, and that's what took me by surprise.
劳拉的书与应对挑战的概念有很多关系。游行要求数不清的志愿者努力、合作和无怨无悔的体力劳动。在某种程度上，这种田园诗般、浪漫的职业道德并不是我来到德斯梅特时所预料的。或者我应该说，这确实是我所预料的，而这正是让我大吃一惊的地方。
Traditionally in a story like this, the writer goes to the place she's dreamt of and finds that it's not like what she imagined at all. But the remarkable thing about De Smet that is that it really is the little town on the prairie. The people are a bit like the people in Laura's books. They're proud of the land they live on. And in a strange way, it's as if Laura's powers of description have affected the way they talk about the place.
传统上，在这样的故事中，作家会去她梦想中的地方，发现它与她想象的完全不同。但德斯梅特的神奇之处在于，它确实是草原上的小镇。人们有点像劳拉书中的人物。他们为自己居住的土地感到自豪。而且以一种奇怪的方式，劳拉的描述能力似乎影响了他们谈论这个地方的方式。
And it's beautiful out here on the prairie this evening, looking at the Big Slough. Herd of cattle over there. I think it looks just like it did in Laura's day. Not all the buildings on the other side, but the Big Slough is the same. I like the way the blackbirds swing in the reeds, the way the cattails bloom, the puddles of water. Sometimes ducks and geese come in and land.
今晚的草原很美，看着大泥沼。那边有一群牛。我觉得它看起来和劳拉那个时代一样。对面的建筑不全是一样的，但大泥沼是一样的。我喜欢黑鸟在芦苇中摇摆的样子，香蒲开花的样子，水坑。有时鸭子和鹅会落下来。
Marian Cramer is the author of the Laura Ingalls Wilder Pageant. We're sitting at a picnic table on the Ingalls Homestead. A busy day of tourism is winding down. Visitors are getting back in their minivans. Tim Sullivan's eight-year-old son, Brian, is assembling his costume for the pageant dress rehearsal. Marian is 65.
玛丽安·克莱默是《劳拉·英格斯·怀尔德游行》的作者。我们坐在英格斯宅地上的野餐桌旁。繁忙的旅游一天即将结束。游客们正在回到他们的微型面包车中。蒂姆·沙利文8岁的儿子布莱恩正在为游行彩排组装他的服装。玛丽安65岁。
So how much different was your life from Laura's when you were reading these books?
当你读这些书时，你的生活和劳拉的生活有多少不同？
Well, I guess my childhood was before electricity, before running water. And I lived on a working farm, and there were chores, there was responsibility. A lot of the same. That's why I like the Laura books so well, because Laura had to do the same things I had to do. We had cattle and hogs and sheep, and we grew wheat and corn. It was a wonderful time. Family was very important. And life seemed simpler then, because we didn't do so many things and go so much. But I'm not sure that it was.
嗯，我想我的童年是在用电之前、有自来水之前。我住在一个工作的农场，有杂务，有责任。很多是一样的。这就是为什么我这么喜欢劳拉书的原因，因为劳拉不得不做我也必须做的事情。我们有牛、猪和羊，我们种小麦和玉米。那是一段美好的时光。家庭非常重要。而且当时的生活似乎更简单，因为我们没有做那么多事情，也没有去那么多地方。但我不确定是否真的更简单。
Do you remember when you first got electricity and water?
你还记得第一次用上电和水吗？
Oh yes.
哦，是的。
And what was that like?
那是什么感觉？
It was just lovely. Electricity came in '48. And they had been working for a long time putting the lines in. And finally the lines were all in, and they were all hooked up. They were just waiting for the major flow of energy. And then the electricity was on. And it was the first time. And that night, as it got dark, I remember my father and my mother and my sister and one of my older brothers, we stood there and looked, because suddenly it wasn't a black country anymore. We could see our neighbors' lights. It made it seem a lot less lonesome, a lot less isolated.
太美好了。电力是在48年进来的。他们花了很多时间安装线路。最后线路全装好了，都连上了。他们只是在等待能量的大规模流动。然后电来了。那是第一次。那天晚上，天黑了，我记得我和父亲、母亲、妹妹以及一个大哥哥，我们站在那儿看，因为突然之间这里不再是一个黑暗的国度了。我们可以看到邻居家的灯光。这让它看起来不再那么孤独，不再那么孤立。
Marian was a music teacher for many years before becoming a pioneer school teacher on the Ingalls Homestead. Every day, she hangs out in the one-room schoolhouse, which looks exactly the way Laura describes her classroom at the Brewster School in her book, These Happy Golden Years . Marian gives brief music and math lessons to the tourists, and then has the class read a quote from Laura off the blackboard. The quote goes something like, "It's best to be truthful and honest and make the best of what we have." Somehow it sounds revelatory.
玛丽安做过多年音乐老师，后来成为英格斯宅地的一名先驱小学老师。每天，她都待在那间单间教室里，看起来和劳拉在她的书《这些幸福的金子年代》中描述她在布鲁斯特学校的教室一模一样。玛丽安给游客简短地上音乐和数学课，然后让全班朗读黑板上劳拉的名言。引语大致是：“最好诚实守信，并充分利用我们所拥有的。”不知为何，这听起来像是一种启示。
The prairie is the only place I've been to in my life where you can make the simplest, sweetest, even, I dare say, most cliched statement about the virtues of a simple life, and it sounds like anything but a cliche. It's as if the wind, which barrels through here like a wild animal, just knocks the irony out of everything. After a long day working at the Ingalls Homestead, Joan Sullivan, Tim's wife, walks me down to the edge of the Big Slough. The grass is taller than we are, and it's easy to see how Mary and Laura could have gotten lost here.
草原是我一生中去过的唯一一个地方，你可以对简单生活的美德发表最简单、甚至可以说最陈词滥调的声明，而它听起来一点也不像陈词滥调。就好像那狂风——像野兽一样咆哮着穿过这里——把一切讽刺都吹走了。在英格斯宅地工作了一整天后，蒂姆的妻子琼·沙利文陪我走到大泥沼边。草比我们还要高，很容易看出玛丽和劳拉是怎么在这里迷路的。
Do you think that has to do with farming? Or do you think it's something about the time that Laura was living in? Or a combination of those?
你认为这与耕种有关吗？还是你认为这是关于劳拉生活的那个时代？或者是两者的结合？
Probably a combination of those, trying to make an honest dollar. A farmer works hard. They feed the world.
可能是两者的结合，试图赚一分诚实的钱。农民工作很努力。他们养活了世界。
Why, hello. I'm glad so many of you have come to our little town on the prairie in De Smet. This is especially fine country, this prairie. At this time of the year, this is the hour that daylight softens and twilight falls. Oh, please forgive me. Sometimes I get a little carried away.
哎呀，你好。很高兴你们这么多人来到我们在德斯梅特草原上的小镇。这是非常好的国家，这片草原。在一年的这个时候，这是日光变柔和、黄昏降临的时刻。哦，请原谅我。有时我有点得意忘形了。
The Laura Ingalls Wilder Pageant runs for three weekends each summer. Admission is $5. About 700 people come each night. It's held right in the middle of the prairie, on land adjacent to the Ingalls Homestead. From the pageant site, you can see the five cottonwood trees that Pa planted. "One for each of my girls," he said, meaning Ma and his four daughters.
《劳拉·英格斯·怀尔德游行》每年夏天连续三个周末举办。门票5美元。每晚约有700人前来。它就在草原中间，紧邻英格斯宅地。从游行地点，你可以看到爸爸种的五棵棉白杨。“每一棵代表我的一位女儿，”他说，指妈妈和他的四个女儿。
The dialogue in the pageant has been prerecorded. When the pageant is actually performed, the cast members lip sync the words and pantomime the action. This technique has its benefits and its perils. During the first performance this year, the actor playing Pa missed his cue, and his words came booming down onto the stage even though he wasn't there. The actors playing Mary and Laura and Ma carried on, talking to an invisible Pa like he was the voice of God.
游行中的对话是预先录制好的。表演时，演员们对口型并表演动作。这种技术既有好处也有风险。今年第一场表演期间，扮演爸爸的演员错过了出场时机，尽管他不在场，他的声音却响亮地传遍了舞台。扮演玛丽、劳拉和妈妈的演员们继续演着，对着一个隐形的爸爸说话，就像他是上帝的声音一样。
Pa, is it on Indian land, or land we'll have to move from?
爸爸，是在印第安人的土地上吗，还是我们需要搬离的土地？
Not on Indian land, my pretty girl. This is surveyed land, just waiting for us to call it home.
不是印第安人的土地，我的漂亮女孩。这是经过测量的土地，正等着我们把它称为家。
I want a place that's open, where I can run with the wind.
我想要一个开阔的地方，可以随风奔跑。
Lots of room, Laura.
空间很大，劳拉。
It'll be the Ingalls Homestead. Doesn't that sound fine?
那就是英格斯宅地。听起来不错，对吧？
I am completely charmed by this pageant. Yes, there are mistakes. Yes, you can hear places on the soundtrack where the tape been edited. But all I can think as I watch these people on stage, many of them farmers, retired farmers, and their wives and kids of farmers, is how effectively they capture the feeling of the book. They're not selling anything. There's no agenda other than to celebrate Laura, and the fact that she cared enough about this town to write these books about it.
我被这场游行深深吸引了。是的，有错误。是的，你可以听到录音带里有剪辑痕迹的地方。但我看着台上这些人，很多是农民、退休农民，以及他们的妻子和孩子们，想到的只有他们捕捉到了书中感觉的有效性。他们没有在推销任何东西。除了庆祝劳拉以及她因为关心这个小镇而写下这些书的事实外，没有任何意图。
It's dusk on the prairie, literally. That doesn't sound like something you'd say in earnest. It sounds like a lyric in some cowboy folk song, or a particularly bad line in a romance novel. But it's not. It is simply dusk on the prairie. Little girls in sweaters and pants from the Gap are wearing sunbonnets and standing on the benches to get a better look. Fathers with fussy babies stroll around the fields so their wives can watch the pageant undisturbed. An eight-year-old girl in sneakers and jeans runs through the grass, the wind whipping through her hair, her sunbonnet flying out behind her.
字面意思上的草原黄昏。那听起来不像你会认真说的话。它听起来像某种牛仔民谣里的歌词，或者浪漫小说里特别糟糕的台词。但事实并非如此。这只是草原上的黄昏。穿着Gap毛衣和长裤的小女孩戴着遮阳帽，站在长凳上看得更清楚。带着闹腾婴儿的父亲们在田野里漫步，这样他们的妻子就能不受打扰地观看表演。一个穿着运动鞋和牛仔裤的8岁女孩在草丛中奔跑，风吹过她的头发，遮阳帽在身后飘扬。
The pageant is a huge hit. When the show's over, the audience storms the stage to get the autographs of cast members. People are saying it's the best thing they've ever seen, that this trip to De Smet is the best vacation they've ever had. It's remarkable, really, that in a time when families can take vacations to Disney World, or visit Great Adventure, or even just stay home and watch TV, people will travel all the way to South Dakota to see a world that's described in a series of books.
游行非常成功。演出结束后，观众冲向舞台寻求演员签名。人们说这是他们见过最好的东西，这次德斯梅特之行是他们度过最好的假期。真了不起，在家庭可以去迪士尼世界、参观大冒险乐园，或者只是待在家里看电视的时代，人们竟然会大老远跑到南达科他州看一系列书中所描述的世界。
The Ingalls family managed to make homes for themselves in some of the most unforgiving conditions imaginable, in a cabin in the deep woods, in the banks of a creek, in a shanty surrounded by hundreds of flat, empty acres. But no matter where they lived, Pa played his fiddle, Ma did her sewing, and Laura managed to find delight in the world around her.
英格斯一家设法在难以想象的最严酷条件下为自己安家，在深林的小木屋里，在小溪的岸边，在被数百英亩平坦、空旷的土地包围的棚屋里。但无论他们住在哪里，爸爸拉着小提琴，妈妈做着针线活，劳拉设法在周围的世界中找到了快乐。
Maybe that ability to merge the indoors and the outdoors, the familiar and the unfamiliar, is what all these people are responding to. Maybe that's why there's so much romance in the whole notion of a cabin stuck out in the middle of nowhere. People want to find comfort in an inherently uncomfortable place. They want to see if they can make it through the long winter and still see the beauty in the snow.
也许那种融合室内与室外、熟悉与陌生、体验与未体验的能力，就是所有人都在回应的东西。也许这就是为什么在偏僻地方搭建一个木屋的概念里会有这么多浪漫色彩的原因。人们想在天生不舒适的地方寻找安慰。他们想看看是否能度过漫长的冬季，并依然看到雪中的美景。
Meghan Daum leaves New York City in two weeks to move to Nebraska.
Meghan Daum两周后离开纽约市搬往内布拉斯加州。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachman, Starlee Kine, and Sylvia Lemus. Musical help from Marika Partridge and Terry Hecker. Special thanks today to Bob Carlson at KCRW and Larry Josephson at the Radio Foundation.
嗯，我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼和南希·厄普代克。特约编辑，保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自托德·巴克曼、斯塔丽·金和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。音乐帮助来自玛丽卡·帕特里奇和泰瑞·赫克。特别感谢今天KCRW的鲍勃·卡尔森和广播基金会的拉里·约瑟夫森。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Of you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free, on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请拨打我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电话，312-832-3380。或者您知道，可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们的大多数节目。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wanders into our workspace looking at all the new stuff we've bought and asks,
WBEZ的管理监督人托里·马拉蒂亚，他走进我们的工作空间，看着我们买的所有新东西，问道，
What-- What d-- What-- How-- What's the price?
什么——什么……什么……怎么——价格是多少？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
O! The joy!
哦！真叫人高兴！
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。